Josh Bearman heard this story as a kid. His dad is a physicist and told it to him. And it just stuck with him. He's a reporter. And he checked it out recently.
乔希·比尔曼小时候听过这个故事。他父亲是一位物理学家，曾把这个故事讲给他听。这个故事一直留在他的脑海里。他现在是一名记者，最近专门去核实了一下。
The story is true. It involves two scientists. One you have definitely heard of, Galileo. The other you may not know, you may just vaguely recall. He's one of the big iconic figures of early astronomy, Johannes Kepler. He discovered the laws of planetary motion. He figured out that tides were caused by the moon's gravity. He's a big guy.
这个故事是真的。它涉及两位科学家。一位是你肯定听说过的伽利略。另一位你可能不太熟悉，或者只有模糊的印象。他是早期天文学中响当当的标志性人物之一——约翰内斯·开普勒。他发现了行星运动定律，并推断出潮汐是由月球引力引起的。他是个大人物。
And in the year 1610, Galileo is in Italy. Kepler is in Prague. And Kepler is further along in his career. He's a court astronomer. Galileo had just made his first telescope a year before.
1610年，伽利略在意大利，开普勒在布拉格。此时的开普勒在职业生涯中已经走得更远，他是一位宫廷天文学家。而伽利略在一年前才刚刚制造出他的第一台望远镜。
And Josh says Galileo and Kepler, they're writing back and forth.
乔希说，当时伽利略和开普勒通过书信往来。
And Galileo, at a certain point, decided to communicate one of his very important discoveries to Kepler with an anagram, which is essentially a word scramble.
伽利略在某个时刻决定，用变位词——本质上就是一种文字重组——来向开普勒传达他的一项重要发现。
Right. He just scrambles the letters. Wait, wait, why does he decide to do that?
没错。他只是把字母顺序打乱了。等等，他为什么要那样做呢？
Well, there's a couple of purposes. One is he's sending the message in code so that at some later date he can always unscramble the code and say, see, as of this date, I had made this discovery. Essentially, the anagram was some kind of, like, patent or copyright insurance on the idea or the discovery.
嗯，有几个目的。其一是通过代码发送信息，以便日后他可以随时解密并宣称：“看，早在那个日期，我就已经有了这个发现。”本质上，这个变位词就像是一种专利，或者说是对这一想法或发现的版权保障。
Remember science itself is so new. There aren't scientific journals yet. Short of publishing a little book, this was the kind of thing you had to resort to to prove that you found something.
请记住，当时的科学本身还很新，还没有科学期刊。除了写本小册子出版，这就是你证明自己有所发现必须采取的手段。
And the anagrams were publicity. They were a way for Galileo to generate interest in his work.
此外，变位词也是一种宣传。这是伽利略为自己的工作制造关注度的一种方式。
To get the attention of the great Kepler at the Royal Court. And they're kind of toying with poor Kepler.
为了引起皇家宫廷中伟大的开普勒的注意。而且，他们当时有点在戏弄可怜的开普勒。
One of Kepler's guys in Prague even writes Galileo at one point, stop toying with us. Tell us what it means.
开普勒在布拉格的一位助手甚至一度致信伽利略，要求他“别再戏弄我们了，告诉我们那是什么意思”。
So the first anagram was about Saturn's rings. Galileo had seen that Saturn had rings. The anagram itself was just a jumble of letters, didn't make any sense.
第一个变位词是关于土星环的。伽利略发现土星有环。那个变位词本身就是一堆字母，根本看不出什么意义。
And he sent it. And several months go by. And Kepler is thinking, OK, great. I'm going to decode the anagram. And then he's having trouble. And he actually keeps asking Galileo, like, come on. I want to know what's in here.
他发出了这串字母。几个月过去了，开普勒心想：“好吧，太棒了，我要破解这个变位词。”但他遇到了困难。他不断地问伽利略：“拜托，我想知道这里面写了什么。”
And Galileo refuses. And then Kepler decodes it himself and comes up with what he thinks the solution is and then publishes that solution. But he was wrong.
伽利略拒绝透露。后来开普勒自己尝试解密，并提出了他认为的答案，还发表了出来。但他错了。
I mean, Galileo's message in Latin was, [LATIN].
我是说，伽利略用拉丁文写的信息是：[拉丁文]。
Meaning roughly, I've observed the highest planet, which was Saturn. That was the furthest planet they knew about at the time. And it's made of three bodies.
大致意思是：我观察到了最高的那颗行星，也就是土星。那是当时他们所知的最远的一颗行星。它由三个天体组成。
Meaning he thought that there were actually two. He thought the rings were two little orbiting-- he didn't quite see that they were rings yet. But then, ultimately, that's what they were discovered to be.
意思是，他以为实际上有两个天体。他以为那是两个小小的轨道卫星——他还没完全看出那是环。但最终，人们发现那确实是环。
And Kepler decoded it thinking, with very sort of bad Latin-- he really had to kind of wrestle the Latin into place to make it work out. But he thought it was saying that Mars has two moons, actually. [LATIN]. So that's kind of some--
开普勒解密时认为——他用的是非常蹩脚的拉丁文——他真的费了很大劲才把这些拉丁文拼凑起来让它说得通。但他认为那句话的意思是火星有两颗卫星。[拉丁文]。所以这就是某种……
And what's what mean?
那意味着什么？
--half Latin. That means, hail, double knob, children of Mars.
那是半拉丁文。意思是：向火星的两个小卫星致敬，双瘤（double knob）。
You heard that right, hail, double knob, children of Mars. Which Josh says, even for the time, even in Latin, didn't sound so great.
你没听错，向“双瘤”、火星的孩子们致敬。乔希说，即使在当时，即使用拉丁文，这听起来也不怎么高明。
You know the double knob, the children are Mars's two moons.
你知道的，“双瘤”就是火星的两颗卫星。
He sort of thought, based on the way he viewed the universe, which had this kind of mystical, numerological sensibility, that Mars ought to have two moons. So he thought, well, of course. That's what this must mean. And he sort of unscrambled the words to make Latin symbolic phrases that meant Mars had two moons.
他根据自己对宇宙的看法——带有一种神秘的数字命理感——认为火星应该有两颗卫星。所以他心想：“哦，当然了，这一定就是它的意思。”于是他把这些词重新组合，拼凑出表示火星有两颗卫星的拉丁短语。
So he sort of interpreted it how we wanted, essentially. But that was not what Galileo was trying to say at all. However, it turned out to be correct.
所以他基本上是按自己的意愿去解读的。但这根本不是伽利略想表达的意思。然而，巧合的是，这竟然是正确的。
Mars does have two moons.
火星确实有两颗卫星。
Mars does have two moons. It was not known for another 200-some-odd years, quite some time, that Mars had two moons. But it does.
火星确实有两颗卫星。直到200多年后，过了相当长一段时间，人们才发现火星有两颗卫星。但它确实有。
These moons would be impossible for Kepler or anybody to see with the technology at the time. But Kepler just wanted them to be there. And he got lucky.
以当时的技术，开普勒或者任何人都不可能看见这些卫星。但开普勒就是希望它们存在。而且他走运了。
And not long after Kepler gets this first anagram wrong, though sort of weirdly right--
在开普勒第一次解密错误——虽然某种程度上歪打正着——之后不久……
Galileo sent another anagram, saying, here's another great discovery. I've looked through my magical eye piece. And check this out.
伽利略又发来了另一个变位词，说：“这是另一个伟大的发现。我用我的魔法目镜观察到了。快看看这个。”
In that case, what Galileo had seen was that Venus has phases. like the moon.
在这种情况下，伽利略看到的是金星有相位变化，就像月球一样。
In other words, there's a quarter Venus, and then half Venus, and 3/4 Venus, and full Venus. Which meant that it must probably be going around the Sun, which was a really big deal. Galileo was in the process of gathering evidence that the Sun was at the center of the solar system and not the Earth, which of course was not just in dispute at the time but actual heresy.
换句话说，金星有四分之一圆、半圆、四分之三圆和满圆形态。这意味着它很可能是绕着太阳运行的，这是一个了不得的大发现。伽利略当时正处于收集证据的阶段，以证明太阳是太阳系的中心，而不是地球。这在当时不仅有争议，甚至是异端邪说。
So that was a big discovery. That one, actually, the anagram itself, the words that Galileo sent, did mean something. And they were sort of like, oh, I'm not quite ready to say what I'm saying here.
所以那是一个重大发现。对于那一次，其实变位词本身、伽利略发送的词汇确实是有意义的。它们的意思大约是：“噢，我还没完全准备好说出这里面的内容。”
In Latin.
用拉丁文。
In Latin. Although it's funny, because there were just a couple of extra letters. Like, he made the anagram. And then there was O, Y. And he's like, I don't know what to do with these. And they're just hanging on the end.
用拉丁文。虽然很有趣，因为多了几个字母。就像他造了这个变位词，后面还剩下“O”和“Y”。他心想：“我不知道怎么处理这两个字母。”它们就那样挂在末尾。
And it looks like he's saying, I'm not quite ready to say this, oy. Like, you know, palm to the forehead, sitting there with some matzo ball soup and a telescope.
看起来他就像在说：“我还没准备好说这个，唉（oy）。”就像你拍着额头，坐在那儿一边喝着面团丸子汤，一边拿着望远镜。
So in Latin, this scramble message-- and you should write this down if you're trying to match wits with these guys at home-- was [LATIN]. Unscrambled, it delivers the news that Venus has phases, like the moon. But, shocker, Kepler does not figure that out.
所以，用拉丁文写的这串重组信息——如果你在家想和这些人比比智慧，你最好记下来——是[拉丁文]。解密后，它传达的消息是：金星像月球一样有相位变化。但是，令人震惊的是，开普勒并没有破解出来。
An he thinks that what Galileo is saying with that anagram is that Jupiter has a red spot that moves according to a mathematical-- there's a phrase that's like, Jupiter's red spot moving mathematically, or something. Which, of course, also is true and also unknown for another 200 years.
他认为伽利略那个变位词想说的是：木星有一个红斑，而且它是按照某种数学规律运动的……大概有这样一个短语，类似“木星红斑的数学运动”。当然，这也是事实，而且同样在接下来的200年里不为人知。
Jupiter does have a red spot on it.
木星确实有一个红斑。
And it moves around the planet. And so Kepler was right, even though he was wrong, sort of reading into this message something that he wanted to see.
而且它会绕着行星移动。所以开普勒又蒙对了，尽管他本质上是错的，只是把某种他想看到的东西强行解读进了这条信息里。
As Josh points out, this is a crazy guess. For Kepler to think that that other anagram meant Mars has two moons, well, having two moons is kind of a normal thing. The Earth has one moon. They could see four moons around Jupiter at the time. Mars might have two moons.
正如乔希指出的，这是一个疯狂的猜测。对于开普勒来说，认为那个变位词意味着火星有两颗卫星，嗯，有两颗卫星是很正常的事。地球有一颗月亮，当时他们也能看到木星周围有四颗卫星。火星可能确实有两颗卫星。
The red spot just sort of makes no sense. And that was as random a guess as you could imagine.
但那个红斑就毫无道理了。那是你所能想象到的最随机的猜测。
Oh, right. We don't think that planets will have just, like, a big red spot on them.
哦，对。我们一般不会认为行星上会有个大红斑。
Yeah. And I remember even when my dad was telling me about this, I asked him if he knew. And he said, no, he couldn't have known unless he was an alien, and he had visited Jupiter. Which is not likely.
是的。我记得连我父亲跟我讲这个故事时，我问他他是否知道。他说，不，除非他是外星人，去过木星，否则他不可能知道。但这不太可能。
And then my dad, who's a scientist, they always say things are never impossible. He says, it's not impossible. But it's also not very likely.
然后我父亲，作为一名科学家，他们总说事情从来不是绝对不可能的。他说：“不是不可能，但可能性很小。”
[LAUGHS]. That is very rigorous.
（笑）这太严谨了。
Yeah, precision.
是的，精准。
This story stayed with Josh, that a guy would send a message that he probably hopes will never be decoded. And then it gets decoded, but incorrectly. And then the wrong message turns out to be right not once but two times.
这个故事一直留在乔希心里：一个人发出的信息可能希望永远不会被解密。结果被解密了，却解读错了。而错误的解读竟然两次都变成了正确的事实。
It makes you feel like communication between people can misfire in such totally random ways. And that is what today's show is about. We have people trying to send messages of various sorts, including messages delivered through incredible means by questionable messengers, messages from beyond the grave. There's a message delivered entirely by swapping one statue for another in a classroom.
这让你觉得人与人之间的交流会以极其随机的方式出错。这就是今天节目的主题。我们有各种试图发送信息的人，包括通过不可思议的手段、由可疑的信使传递的信息，甚至来自坟墓之外的信息。还有一个故事是关于在一个教室里通过交换两座雕像来传递信息的。
Some of these messages get through accurately, some do not. Some transmit information not intended by anyone.
其中一些信息被准确传达，而另一些则不然。有些传达了无人预期的信息。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Motherhood of the Traveling Pants."
第一幕，“旅行裤的母性”。
We being today with a series of messages that have gone back and forth within one family for over 35 years. They are uncanny. They are mysterious. They are inexplicable in their accuracy. Brian Reed explains.
今天我们以一系列在一个家庭中流传了35年多的信息开始。它们离奇、神秘，而且其准确性令人无法解释。布莱恩·里德为您讲述。
A few weeks ago, I talked to a woman named Melissa Salpietra. She's pregnant, so she had a lot on her mind. But the thing she was obsessing over most-- more than baby names, or strollers, or the new house she and her husband recently bought-- was this package that had arrived in the mail with her name on it.
几周前，我和一位名叫梅丽莎·萨尔彼特拉的女性聊了聊。她怀孕了，所以心事重重。但她最纠结的事情——比宝宝的名字、婴儿车或她和丈夫刚买的新房更让她着迷的——是那个寄到她名下、却还没打开的包裹。
I haven't seen it yet. I have been away from home. And the package came to me at my house in North Carolina. And I've been in New England for the summer.
我还没看呢。我一直在外地。那个包裹寄到了我北卡罗来纳州的家里，而我整个夏天都在新英格兰。
But it probably is some sort of padded manila envelope that you get at, like, Staples or something. And my husband is going to bring it to me this weekend. And if I open it up and there's a pair of pants in it, I'm going to have a boy. But if I open it up and there is a little pink dress, I'm going to be having a girl.
但那可能就是一个你在史泰博等文具店能买到的那种加衬的信封。我丈夫这个周末会把它带给我。如果我打开发现里面是一条裤子，我怀的就是男孩。如果我打开发现是一条粉色的小裙子，我怀的就是女孩。
Now I've never been pregnant before. And I don't have kids. But it's my impression that this is not how an unborn baby's sex is normally determined.
我以前从没怀过孕，也没有孩子。但我印象中，这并不是确定未出生婴儿性别的常规方法。
From what I understand, there are these things called chromosomes and then some procedure known as a sonogram. But in Melissa's family, they don't bother with that stuff. Instead--
据我所知，有所谓的染色体，还有一种叫B超的程序。但在梅丽莎的家族里，他们不屑于搞那些东西。相反——
You get sent the prediction of your sex in the mail. You get not even the prediction, you get sent the foretelling of what you're going to have, a boy or a girl.
你会收到邮寄来的性别预测。甚至不是预测，你会收到关于你怀的是男孩还是女孩的预言。
This is a longstanding tradition in Melissa's family. Three generations have participated in it, more than 20 babies. Family legend is the prediction has been right every time.
这是梅丽莎家族一项由来已久的传统。三代人都参与其中，涉及20多个婴儿。家族传说称，这个预测次次都灵验。
It all began more than 35 years ago with Melissa's great-grandmother, Carmela Calanni, AKA, Nonna. Nonna had moved here from Sicily when she was a teenager. She made her living as a seamstress.
这一切始于35多年前梅丽莎的曾祖母卡梅拉·卡兰尼，又称“奶奶”。奶奶十几岁时从西西里岛移居此地。她靠当裁缝维持生计。
She was quiet, unassuming. She baked bread, and made lasagna from scratch, and went to church every day. But Melissa says there was more to Nonna than met the eye.
她安静、谦逊。她会烤面包，亲手做千层面，每天都去教堂。但梅丽莎说，奶奶身上不只有表面看起来的那样。
The thought was Nonna had some sort of direct line to God. And her and God were like peas in a pod. And she could ask. And she would receive.
大家认为奶奶和上帝有一条某种直接的沟通线路。她和上帝就像连体婴儿一样亲密。她能求，就能得。
So whenever you wanted something, you would ask her. And she would go light a candle for you at the church. And then you'd get it.
所以每当你想要什么，你就会问她。她就会去教堂为你点上一支蜡烛。然后你就真的能如愿以偿。
Hoping to nail that job interview? Talk to Nonna. Trying to buy a new house? Go see Nonna. She didn't even make you kiss her hand.
想搞定那份工作面试？去跟奶奶说。想买新房？去找奶奶。她甚至不需要你亲吻她的手。
So years before Melissa was born, when one of Nonna's grandsons announced that his wife was expecting a baby, he went to Nonna and asked for a little favor. He told her he wanted a boy. Here's Melissa's mom, Mary Annette, who was around at the time.
所以，在梅丽莎出生前几年，当奶奶的一位孙子宣布妻子怀孕时，他去求奶奶帮个小忙。他说他想要个男孩。这是梅丽莎的妈妈玛丽·安内特，当时她也在场。
And so Nonna decided she was going to make sure he has the boy. So she showed up at a family function with this little pair of pants and just said, here. Make the first born be a boy.
于是奶奶决定她要确保他如愿生个男孩。于是她在一次家庭聚会上拿出了这条小裤子，只说：“拿着。让第一个出生的孩子是个男孩。”
Nonna had sewn these pants herself. They were brown polyester with belt loops and a zipper. They looked like a pair of pants your great grandfather might wear if he was the size of a doll. Here's Mary Annette.
奶奶亲手缝了这条裤子。它是棕色的涤纶布料，有腰带扣和拉链。它看起来像你曾祖父穿的那种裤子，如果是娃娃大小的话。这是玛丽·安内特。
You know, we joke. We laughed and thought, oh my God, look at this little polyester pair of pants, little old man pants. And at that time, you didn't do sonograms. You didn't find out the sex of babies before you were born. So we just waited. And when the first born was born, it was a boy.
你知道，我们开玩笑说。我们笑了，心想：“天哪，看看这条涤纶小裤子，像老头穿的裤子。”在那个年代，你不能做B超。你无法在孩子出生前知道性别。所以我们就等着。当第一个孩子出生时，是个男孩。
Did you guys have a moment where you said, oh, wow, Nonna was right?
你们当时有没有一种“噢，哇，奶奶说对了”的感觉？
Yes. We all said that. Oh, hey, she picked it. Great.
是的。我们都说了。噢，嘿，她选对了。太棒了。
Now, just a heads up here. Nonna had this big Sicilian family. And their names are what one might call variations on a theme. There's Mary Annette, Mary Anne, Roseanne, Joanne, Melissa Anne.
顺便提一下，奶奶那个庞大的西西里家族，他们的名字可以被称为“主题变奏”。有玛丽·安内特、玛丽·安、罗珊、乔安、梅丽莎·安。
So the woman who had this first baby boy was Mary Anne. She named her son Tony and stitched his name on the tiny pair of pants. And then for some mysterious reason, without even being instructed by Nonna, when the next woman in the family got pregnant--
所以那个生下第一个男婴的女人是玛丽·安。她在小裤子上绣了儿子的名字“托尼”。后来出于某种神秘的原因，甚至没有奶奶的指示，当家族里下一个女人怀孕时——
She just automatically when she found out I was pregnant, she packaged it up and mailed it to me as a good luck charm.
她得知我怀孕时，就自动把裤子打包寄给了我，当作好运符。
This is Roseanne, the next of Nonna's grand-kids to have a baby.
这是罗珊，奶奶的孙辈中下一个生孩子的。
You know, I just got the pants and assumed I was to have a boy.
你知道，我收到裤子就认定我要生个男孩。
Why? That seems a little bit crazy.
为什么？这听起来有点疯狂。
I know. When I think bad it's like, I don't know, kind of weird. Because honestly, my husband and I never gave it a thought. I mean, we truly did not have a girl's name picked out.
我知道。回想起来，这感觉有点怪。因为老实说，我和我丈夫从未考虑过这个问题。我是说，我们真的连女孩的名字都没想好。
Because you got a little pair of pants in the mail, you just were sure you were having a boy?
因为你收到了一条邮寄来的小裤子，你就确定要生男孩了？
It was meant to be a boy. It was meant to be. It was going to be.
命中注定是个男孩。注定就是这样。它会是的。
And what did you have?
那你生了什么？
I had my son, Tommy.
我生了儿子汤米。
Meanwhile across the Atlantic Ocean, Mary Annette was on the verge of having a baby. She was living in Italy at the time. And she was due just a few weeks after Roseanne.
与此同时，在大西洋彼岸，玛丽·安内特也快要生孩子了。她当时住在意大利。预产期比罗珊晚几周。
So [Roseanne stitched her newborn son's name on the pair of pants.
所以罗珊在裤子上绣了她刚出生儿子的名字。
Packaged it up and mailed it to Mary Annette, thinking that that's what she would want, you know, a boy.
打包寄给了玛丽·安内特，觉得那会是她想要的，你知道，一个男孩。
I wanted the girl. I wanted to be the first one to have the girl in the family.
我想要个女孩。我想要成为家里第一个生女孩的人。
There Mary Annette was, lying in a hospital bed back in the old country, about to go into labor any day, fantasizing about her new baby girl.
当时玛丽·安内特正躺在旧家乡的医院病床上，随时准备临盆，幻想她刚出生的女宝宝。
And my husband comes in after work one day. And he says, I picked up the mail, here. It was this manila envelope.
然后我丈夫有一天下班回来，他说：“我拿了邮件，给你。”那是一个马尼拉信封。
I thought it was pictures of her baby. I thought it was, you know, newborn baby, they sent me pictures. So I opened the envelope. And out falls the little brown pants. And I screamed. I went, oh, bleep, bleep, bleep. [LAUGHS].
我以为那是她宝宝的照片。我以为是，你知道，新生儿照片。于是我打开信封。掉出来的是那条棕色小裤子。我尖叫起来。我说：“噢，该死，该死，该死。”（笑）
You swore?
你骂人了？
I did. I said, oh, no. I wanted the girl.
我骂了。我说：“噢，不。我想要女孩。”
A few days later, Mary Annette had a son.
几天后，玛丽·安内特生了个儿子。
After that, we all looked at Nonna. Then we asked. We all looked at Nonna and said, OK, how about a dress now?
在那之后，我们都看向奶奶。然后我们问了。我们都看着奶奶说：“好吧，现在来条裙子怎么样？”
Nonna abided. She sewed a miniature pink satin dress and gave it to Mary Anne, who was pregnant with her second baby. And the rest was like clockwork.
奶奶答应了。她缝了一条迷你粉色缎面连衣裙，把它给了怀着第二个孩子的玛丽·安。剩下的就像时钟运作一样精准。
Mary Anne had a girl. She sent Roseanne the dress. Roseanne had a girl. She sent Mary Annette the dress. Mary Annette had a girl, and then another girl.
玛丽·安生了个女孩。她把裙子寄给了罗珊。罗珊生了个女孩。她把裙子寄给了玛丽·安内特。玛丽·安内特生了个女孩，接着又生了一个女孩。
Nonna wasn't directing this. But everyone knew where the power originated. Nonna was batting seven for seven.
奶奶并没有指挥这一切。但大家都知道力量来源于何处。奶奶七投七中。
A few years passed. And then Nonna's prediction powers reached a turning point. Because Mary Annette was the last one to have a boy and the last one to have a girl, which means she had possession of both the pants and the dress. So when Mary Annette's sister-in-law announced that she was having a baby, it was up to Mary Annette alone to decide which one to send. The power to determine the sex of this woman's baby was in Mary Annette's hands.
几年过去了。然后奶奶的预言能力到了转折点。因为玛丽·安内特是最后一个生男孩的，也是最后一个生女孩的，这意味着她同时拥有裤子和裙子。所以当玛丽·安内特的小姑子宣布怀孕时，由玛丽·安内特独自决定寄哪件。决定这个女人孩子性别的力量就在玛丽·安内特手中。
And I'm sitting in my family room getting the pants, getting the dress, getting the envelope ready with her address, her name and address, to send. And then sitting there looking at these two items, I said, I have a choice to make. And I don't know how many times in and out that envelope went the dress or the pants, the dress or the pants, the dress or the pants.
我坐在家庭室里，拿着裤子，拿着裙子，准备好写着她名字和地址的信封。坐在那里看着这两样东西，我说：“我得做个选择。”我不知道那个裙子和裤子被进出信封多少次了：裙子还是裤子，裙子还是裤子，裙子还是裤子。
And I said, I can't play God. I'm going to have to let her choose. So I put the dress and the pants in the envelope, mailed them to her.
然后我说：“我不能扮演上帝。我得让她自己选。”于是我把裙子和裤子一起塞进信封，寄给了她。
I called Mary Annette's sister-in-law, Joanne. She vividly remembers tearing open the envelope, the pants falling onto her kitchen counter, the dress tumbling out right after it. A couple months later, the doctor told her she was having twins.
我给玛丽·安内特的小姑子乔安打了电话。她清楚地记得撕开信封，裤子掉在厨房台面上，裙子紧随其后滑了出来。几个月后，医生告诉她怀的是双胞胎。
Joanne waited until she delivered her twins to find out what sex they were. Though really, she knew all along.
乔安一直等到生下双胞胎才知道他们的性别。虽然真的，她一直都知道。
First off, he says, you have a son. And he handed me the baby. And I was like, oh my God, my boy. I got my boy.
首先，医生说：“你有一个儿子。”他把宝宝递给我。我当时想：“噢，天哪，我的男孩。我得到了我的男孩。”
And then I think they were only born one minute apart. He immediately then said, and you have a daughter. And it was just, of course. It wasn't a surprise to me. [LAUGHS].
然后我想他们出生只隔了一分钟。医生紧接着说：“你还有一个女儿。”这就像是理所当然的。这对我来说一点也不惊讶。（笑）
And were you just blown away?
你当时是不是惊呆了？
Actually, Mary Annette, I think, was more blown away. Because she freaked when I called her.
其实，我想玛丽·安内特更惊呆了。因为我给她打电话时，她吓坏了。
Oh my God, a boy and a girl. Oh my God, what did I do? [LAUGHS]. And I apologized. I did. I said, I'm so sorry. I said, I know they're cute. I don't know if you wanted two at a time. [LAUGHS].
“噢，天哪，一个男孩和一个女孩。噢，天哪，我做了什么？”（笑）我也道歉了。我确实道歉了。我说：“我很抱歉。我说，我知道他们很可爱，但我不知道你是否想要一次来两个。”（笑）
Now Nonna was nine for nine. The statistical odds of getting the prediction right that many times are less than 1 in 500. Not to mention the fact that she predicted a boy girl set of twins.
现在奶奶是九投九中了。预测准确这么多次的统计学概率不到五百分之一。更不用说她还预测出了一对龙凤胎。
And all of this rocketed Nonna from regular old clairvoyant grandma status to legend. The pants and the dress became an institution. Even after Nonna died in 1999, they kept working.
所有这一切将奶奶从普通的千里眼奶奶提升到了传奇地位。裤子和裙子成了某种“制度”。即使奶奶在1999年去世后，它们依然管用。
Kids who'd been predicted themselves the first time around were now having kids of their own. And Nonna kept getting it right. As the years went on, pants/dress protocol was codified.
当年被预测性别的孩子们现在自己也生孩子了。奶奶依然算得很准。随着岁月流逝，裤子/裙子的规矩也固定了下来。
For instance, if someone else got pregnant while you were pregnant, you could not send them your garment until you had your baby. You had to wait until you stitched your child's name onto the pants or the dress. It's just the way it was done.
例如，如果别人在你怀孕期间也怀孕了，在你自己生下孩子之前，你是不能把衣服寄给她们的。你必须等到把孩子的名字缝在裤子或裙子上才行。规矩就是这样。
And there were some close calls. There was one rogue baby, where the parents received neither the pants nor the dress. They had a boy.
期间也有些惊险时刻。有一个“流浪宝宝”，父母既没收到裤子也没收到裙子。他们生了个男孩。
And the dress was misplaced for a couple of years. Though naturally, only boys were born during that period. It then miraculously resurfaced just in time for the next girl.
裙子也遗失了几年。虽然自然地，在那期间出生的全是男孩。后来它奇迹般地在下一个女孩出生前及时现身了。
I went through the family tree. And it turns out that of 21 predictions, Nonna was wrong two times. Most family members were vague about this. They kind of had a sense that something might have gone awry a couple times. But they were hazy on the details.
我研究了族谱。结果发现，在21次预测中，奶奶错了两次。大多数家庭成员对此含糊其辞。他们有一种感觉，好像有几次出了偏差，但细节上都很模糊。
But when I talked to Rick Salpietra, who lives out in California, he was clear about it. He had two kids for whom Nonna's prediction wasn't right.
但当我与住在加州的里克·萨尔彼特拉交谈时，他很清楚。他有两个孩子是奶奶预测错误的。
It happened 18 years ago. Rick's twin brother Ron sent him the dress. And it predicted Rick's first daughter correctly. But then his brother sent him the pants. And despite that, Rick's second child was a girl.
那是18年前发生的事。里克的孪生兄弟罗恩把裙子寄给了他。它正确预测了里克的第一个女儿。但后来他兄弟又寄来了裤子。尽管如此，里克的第二个孩子还是个女孩。
When Rick's wife got pregnant a third time, and they had sent the dress away but still had the pants in their possession, they had another girl. The family has theories about what went wrong here. Maybe it was geography, the fact that Rick lives in California, so far away from the rest of the family.
当里克的妻子第三次怀孕时，他们已经把裙子寄走了，但手里还有裤子，结果又生了个女孩。家族对于这里出了什么问题有各种理论。也许是地理原因，里克的家在加州，离家族其他成员太远了。
Or maybe it was because these two girls were the last kids in their generation. Nonna was at the end of her life when they were born and died not long after. It's possible her powers were diminished.
或者也许是因为这两个女孩是她们那一代中最后的孩子。奶奶生她们时已近暮年，不久后就去世了。可能她的能力减弱了。
Still, the odds of Nonna predicting the sex correctly as many times as she did-- 19 of 21 babies-- are remarkable. I ran her record by several statisticians. And they said the odds are roughly 1 in 10,000.
尽管如此，奶奶预测性别准确率如此之高——21个婴儿中有19个——依然非同寻常。我把她的记录拿给几位统计学家看，他们说概率大约是万分之一。
Whatever the reason for her being wrong those two times, while lots of people in the family are still really into the pants and the dress, Rick, the father of the girls who were incorrectly predicted, says he purposely avoids talking to his daughters about the tradition, even though they're teenagers now.
无论她那两次失误的原因是什么，尽管家族中很多人依然非常沉迷于裤子和裙子，但作为那些预测错误女孩的父亲，里克说他刻意避免与女儿谈论这个传统，即使她们现在已经是青少年了。
My middle daughter is sort of the more quiet, sensitive one. And I think she might be a little upset if she actually thought that the whole thing sort of broke down when it came to us getting the pants or the dress on her pregnancy. And I don't know if I'd want to do that to her.
“我二女儿比较安静、敏感。我想如果她真的认为在她的怀孕阶段整个事情失灵了，她可能会有点难过。我不知道我是否想对她那样做。”
Yeah, it's a weird thing to have to tell your kid.
是的，告诉孩子这件事挺奇怪的。
It is. I mean, I don't know what to say. I wouldn't want her to feel bad. I really wouldn't.
确实。我是说，我不知道该说什么。我不希望她感觉糟糕。真的不希望。
I had no clue up until I got pregnant that this would weigh so heavily on me.
直到我怀孕，我都没意识到这件事会给我带来这么大的压力。
Melissa, the woman who's pregnant right now, is desperately hoping that she never needs to sit down with her kid one day and say, you were inaccurately predicted. You were a weak link.
梅丽莎，那位现在怀孕的女性，绝望地希望她将来有一天不需要坐下来对孩子说：“你的性别预测不准。你是个薄弱环节。”
At first she was really excited to get the pants or the dress, to take part in the tradition. After all, Melissa was predicted herself. Her name is on the dress. But now she's just really worried that it'll be wrong.
起初她非常兴奋能收到裤子或裙子，参与这一传统。毕竟，梅丽莎本人也是被预测出来的。她的名字就绣在裙子上。但现在她真的很担心会出错。
I mean, I'm embarrassed to actually say how much anxiety that it kind of has caused.
我是说，我甚至羞于启齿这引起了多大的焦虑。
Melissa's due in about three months. Remember, the situation right now is that her husband has received the package with the pants or the dress in it. But they're waiting to see each other before they open it.
梅丽莎还有三个月预产期。记住，目前的情况是她丈夫已经收到了装着裤子或裙子的包裹。但他们等着见面后再打开。
Melissa really wants a boy. So she requested the pants from her sister-in-law. And she's guessing that's what's in the package, the pants. Though it is possible that some people in the family conspired to send her the dress against her will. That has happened before.
梅丽莎真的很想要个男孩。所以她向小姑子要了裤子。她猜包裹里装的就是裤子。虽然不排除家族里有些人违背她的意愿合谋寄给她裙子的可能。这种事以前发生过。
To add to the pressure, when Melissa and her husband went for their last ultrasound, they asked the doctor to write down the baby's sex and seal in an envelope for them to open later if they want to.
为了增加压力，梅丽莎和丈夫上次做B超检查时，请医生写下胎儿性别并密封在一个信封里，让他们以后想看时再打开。
I don't know. It's like this, we put ourselves in this situation now where we have two envelopes to open. Not just one but two. And they can conflict.
我不知道。就像这样，我们现在陷入了这种局面，有两个信封要打开。不止一个，是两个。而且它们可能会冲突。
Would you rather have a boy but have the prediction be wrong? Or would you rather have a girl and have the prediction be right?
你是宁愿要个男孩但预测错了？还是宁愿要个女孩但预测对了？
I would rather have the prediction be right.
我宁愿预测是对的。
You didn't even hesitate with that question.
你在回答这个问题时甚至都没有犹豫。
No. I want the prediction. I want the prediction to be right.
没有。我想要那个预测。我想要预测是准确的。
[PEOPLE CHATTING]
（人们聊天声）
A few days after I interviewed Melissa, I went to her baby shower in Ohio. She had the ultrasound prediction with her. And she and her husband were thinking about looking at it at some point during the day. The night before, they'd opened the package with Nonna's prediction. And drumroll, please.
采访梅丽莎几天后，我去参加了她在俄亥俄州的迎婴派对。她带着B超的预测单。她和丈夫考虑过在派对期间找个时间看看。前一天晚上，他们打开了装着奶奶预言的包裹。击鼓请准备。
I got the pants. Opened up the package, and the pants were inside.
我拿到了裤子。打开包裹，里面是裤子。
Which should have been great news, right? Melissa wants a boy.
那应该是天大的好消息，对吧？梅丽莎想要个男孩。
Are you excited?
你兴奋吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Yes, I am. I'm glad to have them. I thought I was going to feel a lot more confident that it would be a boy. But I still don't.
嗯。嗯。是的，我很兴奋。我很高兴拿到裤子。我以为我会更有信心它是男孩。但我现在还是没信心。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Put a onesie on a onesie, on a onesie, on a onesie.
把连体衣穿在连体衣上，再穿在连体衣上。
Throughout the day, Melissa tried to just enjoy her baby shower and keep her mind off the very obvious question at hand. But it was hard to ignore the fact that many of the activities were aggressively gender neutral, like the designs that women ironed onto outfits for the new baby. There were giraffes, zebras, hats, umbrellas, but no pink ponies or blue dump trucks. There was the name game, led by Melissa's mom Mary Annette, Which had both a girls' round--
这一整天，梅丽莎试图享受她的迎婴派对，把心思从那个显而易见的问题上移开。但很难忽略这样一个事实：很多活动都刻意保持性别中立，比如女人们熨烫在新生儿衣服上的图案。有长颈鹿、斑马、帽子、雨伞，但没有粉色小马或蓝色自卸卡车。还有一个名字游戏，由梅丽莎的妈妈玛丽·安内特主持，有女孩组的回合——
The beginning of the day.
一天的开始。
Dawn.
黎明（Dawn）。
Correct. This month is the first one of summer.
正确。这一月是夏天的第一个月。
June.
六月（June）。
The night before a holiday.
节假日的前一天。
Eve.
前夕（Eve）。
And a boys' round. Though the boys' round was harder.
还有一个男孩组的回合。虽然男孩组的更难。
Some people need ropes to climate it.
有些人需要绳子才能爬上去。
Cliff.
悬崖（Cliff）。
Cliff! Cliff!
克里夫（Cliff）！克里夫！
Cliff. Certain cut of beef.
克里夫。某种切块的牛肉。
Chuck.
牛颈肉（Chuck）。
Chuck beef.
牛颈牛肉。
Oh, what about Angus?
噢，安格斯呢？
Angus?
安格斯？
Angus is a name.
安格斯是个名字。
That's not a cut of beef. That's the name of the cow.
那不是牛肉切块。那是牛的名字。
Finally, later that night after most of the shower guests went home, it was time to tear off the Bandaid.
最后，那天晚上大多数客人回家后，是时候揭开谜底了。
Go get Mom and Domenic.
去把妈妈和多梅尼克叫来。
It was time for the moment of truth. Melissa and her husband went into a bedroom with the ultrasound envelope and shut the door behind them. The family huddled anxiously outside.
这是决定性的时刻。梅丽莎和丈夫带着B超信封走进卧室，关上了门。家人们在门外焦急地挤在一起。
Is it freaky that we're all just outside the door waiting.
我们都在门外等着是不是有点诡异。
Quietly talking.
小声说话。
I feel like the baby's actually being born right now.
我感觉孩子好像现在就要出生了一样。
I feel like I'm waiting for the smoke, and the pope, and the whole thing. [LAUGHS].
我感觉就像是在等烟雾，等教皇，等整套程序。（笑）
Minutes passed. Then, slowly, the door opened. Melissa emerged.
几分钟过去了。然后，门慢慢打开了。梅丽莎走了出来。
It's a boy!
是个男孩！
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
Melissa went around hugging everyone. Her brother, Nonna prediction number three. Her cousin, Nonna prediction number five. Her sister, Nonna prediction number seven.
梅丽莎走过去拥抱每个人。她哥哥，奶奶预言的三号。她表亲，奶奶预言的五号。她姐姐，奶奶预言的七号。
Finally, she could wipe the sweat off her brow and breathe a sigh of relief. Not only was she getting the boy she wanted, she could call Nonna's relatives all over the country without shame or disappointment and tell them that number 23 was right.
终于，她可以擦掉额头的汗水，长舒一口气了。她不仅得到了想要的男孩，还可以不带羞愧和失望地给全国各地的亲戚打电话，告诉他们第23次预测又对了。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
Laura.
劳拉。
Yeah.
嗯。
I'm calling to tell you that Nonna was right again.
我打电话是告诉你，奶奶又说对了。
Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. That is so crazy. I have goosebumps.
噢，我的天哪。噢，我的天哪。这太疯狂了。我起鸡皮疙瘩了。
Do you? [LAUGHS].
真的吗？（笑）
Brian Reed is one of the producers of our program.
布莱恩·里德是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, "Message In a Bottle."
第二幕，“漂流瓶中的信息”。
This is another story of people communicating not with words but with an inanimate object. Dave Hill has been on our show from time to time. He's a comedian and a musician.
这是另一个关于人们不使用语言，而是通过一个无生命物体进行交流的故事。戴夫·希尔不时会来我们的节目。他是一位喜剧演员和音乐家。
He told this story onstage at Cameo Gallery in Brooklyn. A warning for the squeamish, he mentions pee in here.
他在布鲁克林的卡梅奥画廊台上讲了这个故事。给胆小者一个提醒，他在这里提到了尿液。
This is something that happened to me a few weeks ago right here in town. But backing things up a little bit. I moved here to New York in 2003 from Cleveland. Thank you!
这是几周前就发生在我身上的一件事，就在城里。但先退回一点点。我2003年从克利夫兰搬到这里来。谢谢！
[LIGHT APPLAUSE]
（轻微的掌声）
Thank you. Anyway, the time that I've been here-- maybe you guys can relate to this, too-- all I ever hear is, New York used to be so edgy. But now it's lost its edge. It's not edgy anymore.
谢谢。不管怎样，我待在这里的这段时间——也许你们也能感同身受——我听到的全是：“纽约曾经那么前卫，但现在它失去了锐气。它不再前卫了。”
Because I understand that there was a time in New York when you could walk down the street, and just crack open a beer, and just suck it down, and throw the bottle on the ground.
因为我明白，纽约曾有一个时期，你可以走在大街上，打开一瓶啤酒，一饮而尽，然后把瓶子扔在地上。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And you might get, like, a little raped, or whatever.
然后你可能会被稍微强奸一下，或者是别的什么。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
But it didn't matter. It was like a give and take. You took the good with the bad. And everyone was fine with it.
但这没关系。这就像是一种给予和索取。你接受好的同时也接受坏的。每个人都对此感到没问题。
And now you can't really get away with any of that stuff. But you can get a really nice brunch at a lot of places. Just go with your friends, free refills on mimosas. It's great for everybody.
而现在你真的不能随心所欲地做那些事了。但你可以在很多地方享受到非常棒的早午餐。和朋友一起去，含羞草鸡尾酒免费续杯。这对每个人都很好。
And the reason I bring this up is a few weeks ago I was doing a show out here in Brooklyn. It was a very classy show with all these people, and a sold out show. So I put on a fancy suit. And I spent, like, six to eight hours on my hair.
我提起这个的原因是几周前我在布鲁克林做一场演出。那是一场非常高级的演出，观众全是这类人，门票售罄。所以我穿了一套考究的西装。我还花了六到八个小时搞我的头发。
And the people putting the show on were like, oh, Dave, you've got to get out here on time. So I'm rushing to get out there. And I'm at 28th and Broadway. And the R train's right there.
组织演出的人催我：“噢，戴夫，你得准时赶到那儿。”所以我急着出门。我在百老汇大道28街。R线地铁就在那儿。
So I'm like, oh, I'll take the R train. That's like a reputable train. And right before I'm going to go on the subway, I realize, oh, I'm so hungry. And then I look. And there's a gyro car right there.
所以我心想：“噢，我会坐R线地铁。”那是趟靠谱的地铁。就在我准备进入地铁之前，我意识到：“噢，我太饿了。”然后我抬头一看。那儿正好有个希腊旋转烤肉车。
So I go to the gyro guy. I'm like, give my a gyro. And then he's got all the sauces, like the yogurt sauce, and the chili sauce, and the garlic sauce. And I'm just like, sauce the [BLEEP] out of that thing. And don't hold back on me.
所以我走到那个人面前。我说：“给我来个肉卷。”他有各种酱汁，像酸奶酱、辣椒酱、蒜蓉酱。我就说：“把这东西给我狠狠地加酱。别跟我客气。”
And he just starts just hosing down the gyro. Like, calm down. And then finally, he gives me the gyro.
于是他开始往肉卷上浇水似的加酱。我心想：“冷静点。”最后他把肉卷给了我。
And I go down into the subway. And the train comes right away. I get on it with the gyro. I start eating the gyro. And the sauces just start dripping all over my hands, and on the ground, and on my shoes and everything. And it's rush hour. And the train's, like, super crowded, and everything.
我走进地铁站。车马上就来了。我带着肉卷上了车。我开始吃肉卷。酱汁开始滴得到处都是：滴在我的手上、地上、鞋子上，到处都是。正好赶上高峰期。地铁超级拥挤。
And I'm realizing, oh, I'm probably stinking up the whole car with this gyro. And people are probably looking at me thinking, that guy looks incredible. But it's not very cool what he's doing with that gyro.
我意识到：“噢，我可能用这个肉卷把整个车厢弄得臭气熏天。”大家可能都在看着我想：“那个人看起来帅呆了，但他用肉卷搞出的动静不太酷。”
So I'm thinking the best thing that I can do for everyone on the train, and for the city of New York in general, is just get off the subway at the next stop, finish the gyro, get back on, go out to Brooklyn. And so I get off at the next stop, 23rd Street. Lightning quick decision.
所以我心想，我能为列车上的人，也为纽约市所做的最好的事，就是在下一站下车，吃完肉卷，再上车去布鲁克林。于是我在下一站——23街——下了车。闪电般的决定。
And then I walk all the way to the end of the platform to eat my gyro. Because I don't even want to bother anyone on the platform with my gyro. I do cool [BLEEP] like this all the time.
然后我一直走到站台尽头去吃我的肉卷。因为我甚至不想在站台上用我的肉卷打扰任何人。我总是做这种很酷的事。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And so I go all the way down to the end of the platform. And you know how at the end of the subway they have the black metal storage bins? Not like a Norwegian black metal storage, which would be so cool. It's just like a regular black metal storage, almost like a dumpster or something.
于是我走到站台最尽头。你们知道地铁尽头都有那种黑色金属储物箱吧？不是那种挪威黑金属那种（那是多酷啊），只是普通的黑色金属储物箱，几乎就像垃圾桶什么的。
So I'm stand next to it. And I've finished my gyro. And then I have the wrapper. And I'm looking around for a trash can to throw it out. And there's no trash can anywhere on the whole platform.
我就站在它旁边。我吃完了肉卷。手里拿着包装纸。我环顾四周想找个垃圾桶扔掉它。但整个站台上压根就没有垃圾桶。
And it's too messy to put in my pocket. And I'm like, oh, I don't want to throw it on the ground. I don't want to throw it on the track.
而且它太脏了，不能放进我的口袋。我心想：“噢，我不想把它扔在地上。我也不想扔在轨道上。”
So I think the best thing that I can do in this scenario is just set it down on the black metal storage bin. That way, whoever has to clean it up later, they don't have to bend over. They can just kind of swoop it into the satchel. I might be kind of fun for them. I don't even know.
所以我认为在这种情况下我能做的最好的事，就是把它放在那个黑色金属储物箱上。这样，之后负责清理的人就不用弯腰了。他们可以直接把它扫进袋子里。这可能对他们来说挺有趣的。我甚至都不知道。
And so I set it down. And as soon as I do, I start to hear this rustling, and rumbling, and [GROWLING SOUNDS]. And it turns out there's this homeless guy sort of camped out on the other side of the storage bin. And I woke him up.
于是我把它放了上去。刚放好，我就开始听到沙沙声、隆隆声和……（低吼声）。原来有个流浪汉就睡在储物箱的另一边。我把他吵醒了。
And he's like this sleeping giant, just like, [GROWLING SOUNDS]. And he gets up. And his bones are creaking. And his hair is, like, all crazy all over the place. And he looks at me. And he just starts yelling. And he's like, back up! Back up!
他就像个沉睡的巨人，在那儿（低吼声）。他站起来。他的骨头在吱吱作响。他的头发乱蓬蓬的。他看着我。开始大喊大叫。他吼道：“退后！退后！”
And I move like a little bit. But I'm like, what's this guy going to do? So I don't really move that much.
我退了一点。但我心想：“这家伙想干嘛？”所以我没怎么动。
But then he's like, back up! And get this trash out of here. And he smacks the trash out at me. And I'm like, that's rude.
但随后他又喊：“退后！把这些垃圾给我拿走。”他把垃圾向我挥去。我心想：“这太粗鲁了。”
And then he screams again. He's like, back up! Back up! And this guy, like, he was seriously homeless. It wasn't like a phase he was going through, where he's like, oh, that's Don. I'm sure he'll be back up in his place any day now. He is like this seriously crazy, caveman homeless guy.
然后他又尖叫：“退后！退后！”这个家伙，他是真正无家可归的。这不是他正经历的某种阶段，那种人们说：“噢，那是唐，我肯定他随时都会回到正常生活。”他就是那种真正疯狂的、穴居人式的流浪汉。
So it occurs to me. It's like, this might not even be about me. He might be yelling at some other guy, imaginary guy, who's just like standing exactly where I'm standing. So I'm still not really moving.
于是我想到。这可能根本不是针对我。他可能是在冲另一个人喊，一个虚构的家伙，正好站在我站的位置上。所以我还是没怎么动。
So I'm like, oh, the train's coming, whatever. And then he goes, back up or I'll throw this bottle of piss on you! And then from out of nowhere, like a ninja, all of a sudden he's got this Gatorade bottle.
我心想：“噢，车要来了，无所谓了。”然后他喊：“退后，不然我就往你身上扔这瓶尿！”然后不知从哪儿冒出来的，就像忍者一样，他突然掏出个佳得乐瓶子。
And it's a huge Gatorade bottle. It's not like the size you get, like, oh, hang on, I'm just going to the store to get some Gatorade. It's like the giantest size. The kind you drink if you're like, I only drink Gatorade. It's like huge, the hugest size. Only, instead of being full of delicious and refreshing Gatorade, it's full of pee, of urine.
那是巨大的佳得乐瓶子。不是你买的那种普通大小，那种“等等，我正要去商店买佳得乐”的。那是超大号的。那种如果你只喝佳得乐的话才会喝的。它是巨大的，最大的那种。只不过，里面装的不是美味清爽的佳得乐，而是尿，是尿液。
And just real quick, has anyone here ever peed in a bottle before?
快速问一下，这里有人曾经在瓶子里尿过吗？
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Oh, yeah. Of course. But yeah, I was just doing it before.
噢，当然。不过，我刚以前做过。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
But the reason I bring it up is if you haven't peed in a bottle before, you think when you have to go really bad you're like, oh my God, I just went like nine gallons. It was crazy. But we don't, as humans-- and you know this if you've peed in a bottle-- we actually don't pee that much.
但我提起这个的原因是，如果你以前没在瓶子里尿过，你可能会想：“当我想尿急时，我肯定尿了九加仑，太疯狂了。”但作为人类——如果你在瓶子里尿过你就会知道——我们其实尿不了那么多。
Now the reason I bring it up is because to fill a huge Gatorade bottle, that's like a week or two's worth of urine. Now if you factor in that the homeless are a historically dehydrated people, this is like three or four weeks of pee saved up.
我提起这个的原因是，要装满一个巨大的佳得乐瓶子，那得是一两周的尿量。如果你考虑到无家可归者在历史上就是缺水的群体，这大概积攒了三四周的尿。
And he's just like, back up or I'll throw this bottle of piss on you! And the way I'm saying it, it sounds like he's like, back up. That's the first option. And if you choose not to do that, I'll throw this bottle of urine that I just happen to have. I'll throw it on you.
他就是在那儿喊：“退后，不然我就往你身上扔这瓶尿！”我说话的方式，听起来像是：“退后。这是第一个选项。如果你选择不退后，我会扔掉我正好带着的这瓶尿。我会扔在你身上。”
But he doesn't say it like that at all. He's just like, back up or I'll throw this bottle of piss on you. And before he even finishes his sentence, he cocks his arm back and just launches it at me.
但他完全不是那样说的。他只是吼：“退后，不然我就往你身上扔这瓶尿！”在他还没说完这句话之前，他手臂向后一拉，直接向我投掷过来。
[AUDIENCE GASPS]
（观众倒吸一口凉气）
I know!
我知道！
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And oh my God, homeless or not, like, not a drop wasted. His aim was incredible. It was just coming right at me. The first blow nails me right in the head. Like all my hair, all that work for nothing. My hair is totally ruined.
噢，天哪，不管是不是流浪汉，一滴都没浪费。他的准头不可思议。直接向我飞过来。第一下直接击中我的头。我的头发，我所有花在头发上的功夫全白费了。我的头发彻底毁了。
It's going down my back and down my jacket. And it's soaking my pants. It soaks through my pants, soaks my underwear. He had effectively wet my pants with his pee.
它顺着我的背和夹克淌下来。还弄湿了我的裤子。它渗过我的裤子，浸湿了我的内裤。他有效地用他的尿尿湿了我的裤子。
And at this point in the story, I'm getting a bit irritated, right? And I'm thinking to myself, well, Dave, what would you do if a total stranger drenched you in his own pee? And up to that point in my life I would have thought like, oh, I'd kill that guy, and hurt his feelings, and really give him a real stern talking to.
讲到故事的这一点，我有点烦躁了，对吧？我对自己心想：“好吧，戴夫，如果一个完全陌生的人把你浇了一身尿，你会怎么办？”在那之前的人生中，我可能会想：“噢，我要杀了那个家伙，伤害他的感情，好好跟他谈谈。”
But that wasn't my reaction at all. I was just like, I am getting the [BLEEP] out of here immediately. Because if you figure if your opponent's first move in a confrontation is to just drench you in his own pee, like, what's next? At the very least, he's got a couple more bottles of pee back there, you figure.
但这根本不是我的反应。我只是想：“我立刻从这儿滚蛋。”因为你想啊，如果你的对手在冲突中的第一招就是把你浇一身尿，那接下来会是什么？至少他后面还有几瓶尿，你是这么想的吧。
So I'm just like, all right, touche. You won this round, well played. I'm getting out of here.
所以我心想：“好吧，touche（你说对了）。这局你赢了，干得好。我闪人。”
And so I walk out of the subway station. And I walk up onto the street. And it's still light outside. And I'm walking down Fifth Avenue.
于是我走出地铁站。我走到街上。外面天还是亮的。我沿着第五大道走。
And I start thrashing around to get the pee off of me. And I'm like Jennifer Beals in hit movie, Flashdance . And it's flying all over. And then the sort of rivulets of hobo pee are running down my face and neck, and down my chest and everything.
我开始疯狂甩动身体想把尿弄掉。我感觉自己像是电影《闪电舞》里的詹妮弗·比尔斯。尿液到处飞溅。然后流浪汉尿的细流顺着我的脸、脖子、胸口到处淌。
And I'm looking up. And I see that. And the sun is kind of going through the droplets of pee. And it's forming these beautiful prisms and rainbows. And I'm just transfixed by them.
我抬头看。我看到了。阳光穿过尿液滴。它们形成了美丽的棱镜和彩虹。我被它们深深吸引了。
And all of a sudden, all that pain and anger just fell away. Because it was in that moment I realized, this mother [BLEEP] town is back.
突然间，所有的痛苦和愤怒都消失了。因为就在那一刻我意识到：“这个混蛋小镇又回来了。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Thank you.
谢谢。
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
（掌声和欢呼声）
Dave Hill, he's the author of the book Tasteful Nudes, and Other Misguided Attempts at Personal Growth and Validation.
戴夫·希尔，他是《有品位的裸体，以及其他个人成长与自我认同的错误尝试》一书的作者。
Coming up, our program has been on the radio for over a decade. And finally, finally we have somebody in the second half of today's program for the first time ever who actually has a great voice for radio. I know you've been wondering if this would ever happen. And yes, it is not one of our contributors. It is one of their dads.
接下来的节目，我们的节目在电台播放已经超过十年了。终于，在今天节目的下半部分，我们第一次迎来了真正拥有绝佳电台嗓音的嘉宾。我知道你们一直好奇这是否会发生。是的，他不是我们的撰稿人之一，而是其中一位撰稿人的父亲。
That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
这将在稍后为您带来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Send a Message," stories of messages sent and received, many of them not using words, or words that mean something different than what they're saying.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目里，我们都会选择一个主题，给你们带来关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“传个信（Send a Message）”，讲述关于信息被发送和接收的故事，其中很多没有使用语言，或者语言本身的意思与它们字面意义不同。
We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "Soul Sister." Sometimes the impressiveness of the messenger is part of what makes a message so powerful. Sonari Glinton has an example of that.
我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“灵魂姐妹”。有时信使的震撼力是信息强大的原因之一。索纳里·格林顿有一个这样的例子。
In the late 1970s, my family moved to a Chicago neighborhood called South Shore. Black families had been moving there for decades. And of course, as we moved in, all the white families moved out.
20世纪70年代末，我家搬到了芝加哥一个叫南岸（South Shore）的街区。黑人家庭几十年来一直搬到那里。当然，随着我们搬入，所有的白人家庭都搬走了。
Which wasn't so bad, partly because when all those white families fled, they left behind all kinds of cool stuff-- golf courses, a few marinas, a gigantic country club, mansions. Mostly, though, they left behind their churches and synagogues.
这其实也不坏，部分原因是在那些白人家庭逃离时，他们留下了各种好东西——高尔夫球场、几个码头、一个巨大的乡村俱乐部、豪宅。但最主要的是，他们留下了他们的教堂和犹太教堂。
One of those churches was my own, Saint Philip Neri Parish. It is a huge church. And it was also my grade school. Right there on 72nd Street, Saint Philip Neri was the beginning and end of my little Catholic universe. Between school, mass on Sundays, basketball, summer camp, I essentially spent my entire childhood there.
其中一座教堂就是我自己的，圣菲利普·内里教区。这是一座巨大的教堂。它也是我的小学。就在第72街上，圣菲利普·内里是我小小天主教宇宙的起点和终点。从学校、周日弥撒、篮球到夏令营，我基本上整个童年都在那里度过。
By the time I was in third grade, Saint Philip Neri's students were nearly all black. And just about half of our teachers were black. Each year, more and more black teachers replaced the white ones.
到了我三年级的时候，圣菲利普·内里的学生几乎全是黑人。我们大约一半的老师也是黑人。每年，越来越多的黑人老师取代白人老师。
South Shore was kind of the same. There were just a few white families left. Sometimes during recess, we'd hear bagpipes coming from the church near the playground and watch as groups of white people left the funeral mass.
南岸（South Shore）的情况也差不多。只剩下几户白人家庭。有时在课间休息时，我们会听到从操场附近的教堂传来的风笛声，看着一群白人离开葬礼弥撒。
But it wasn't just South Shore. Chicago was going through this gigantic change, too. Race was at the forefront of everything. In 1983, Chicago elected its first black mayor, Harold Washington, whose opponents tried to scare voters about a black man holding the job.
但不仅仅是南岸。芝加哥也在经历巨大的变化。种族问题处于一切事情的中心。1983年，芝加哥选出了第一位黑人市长哈罗德·华盛顿，他的反对者试图通过黑人担任职务的传言来恐吓选民。
Harold Washington's election meant a lot to South Shore. It still does. In 1983, Lou's Barber Shop on 71st Street had a poster of Harold Washington hanging up. Lou's still has that picture of Harold.
哈罗德·华盛顿的当选对南岸意义重大。直到现在依然如此。1983年，71街上的卢氏理发店挂着一张哈罗德·华盛顿的海报。卢氏理发店至今还留着哈罗德的那张照片。
But Harold was just the beginning. Soon after his election, Michael Jordan came to town, then Oprah. In 1984, Jesse Jackson-- the dude from our neighborhood-- was running for president.
但哈罗德只是个开始。他当选后不久，迈克尔·乔丹来到了城里，然后是奥普拉。1984年，我们街区的那位杰西·杰克逊正在竞选总统。
But all of that was going on around us. The biggest thing for me happened at Saint Philip Neri. And it happened with Sister Rosemary Brennan.
但所有这一切都在我们周围发生。对我来说最大的事情发生在圣菲利普·内里，而且是与罗斯玛丽·布伦南修女一起发生的。
Sister Rosemary was the principal at Saint Philip Neri. And principal is such a limp title, when I think about it. Because really, Sister Rosemary was the school. Her presence was big, even though by the fourth grade, I was taller than her.
罗斯玛丽修女是圣菲利普·内里的校长。回想起来，“校长”这个头衔太无力了。因为实际上，罗斯玛丽修女就是学校本身。她的存在感很大，尽管到了四年级，我就比她高了。
Sister Rosemary wasn't a nun out of central casting. She'd clearly been a beautiful woman when she was younger. But she didn't wear a habit. She did carry a rosary. She was very Irish, serious, not angry.
罗斯玛丽修女并不是那种从选角中心出来的修女。她年轻时显然是个美女。但她不穿修女服。她确实带着念珠。她很爱尔兰人，严肃，但不愤怒。
Mainly, she took each of us seriously, which came across as love. Her love was fierce. She knew every single kid, every parent. Everything about each of us mattered.
主要的是，她认真对待我们每个人，这传递出一种爱。她的爱很强烈。她认识每一个孩子，每一个家长。我们每个人的每一件事都很重要。
Sister Rosemary didn't talk about race. But what she did, that's a story.
罗斯玛丽修女从不谈论种族。但她所做的，那是另一个故事。
It was sometime after Christmas break. I was in the fourth grade in my reading class. I had Miss Sperling. It seems important to note that she was white.
那是圣诞假期后的某一天。我在四年级的阅读课上。我教的是斯珀林老师。值得一提的是她是白人。
Anyway, we were sitting in reading class. So we're all broke up in groups. And in walks Sister Rosemary. Now Sister Rosemary didn't just walk into a classroom for no reason. Either one of the kids or the teacher was in big trouble.
总之，我们坐在阅读课上。大家分组坐着。这时罗斯玛丽修女走了进来。罗斯玛丽修女是不会无缘无故走进教室的。要么是孩子要么是老师出了大麻烦。
So everyone stopped what they were doing. And she said, as she would always say, good morning boys and girls. And we said what we would always say, well, sing. Good morning, Sister Rosemary.
所以每个人都停止了手中的工作。她就像往常一样说：“大家早上好，男孩女孩们。”我们也异口同声地回答：“罗斯玛丽修女早上好。”
And then Sister Rosemary told us to go back to our work, which was a perfectly silly thing to say. Because when Sister Rosemary was in your class, you paid attention to Sister Rosemary. Even the kindergartners knew that. So our eyes stayed on Sister Rosemary as she grabbed the chair, dragged it across the floor to the front of the room. Then she stood on top of the chair with her back to the class.
然后罗斯玛丽修女让我们继续工作，这是一句完全愚蠢的话。因为当罗斯玛丽修女在你的教室时，你只会关注罗斯玛丽修女。连幼儿园的孩子都知道这一点。所以当她抓起椅子，拖过地板走到教室前面时，我们的眼睛一直盯着她。然后她背对着班级站在椅子上。
In our classroom, just like in every classroom, there was a crucifix. The crucifix had a blond wooden cross with a figure of Christ suspended on it. Then with her back to the class, Sister Rosemary teetered on her tippy toes, firmly grabbed the bottom of the crucifix, and took it off the wall.
在我们的教室里，就像在每个教室一样，挂着一个十字架。那个十字架是一个浅色木十字，上面悬挂着基督的形象。然后背对着全班，罗斯玛丽修女踮着脚尖，稳稳地抓住十字架的底部，把它从墙上取了下来。
By this point, no one was reading or even pretending to pay attention to anything else. She placed the cross aside, reached up, again on her tiptoes, and replaced the old crucifix with a new one. And on this cross was a black Jesus. He was carved out of dark wood with a short 'fro, wide nose, full lips, and the same down-turned face as the white Jesus.
此时，没人再阅读，也没人假装注意其他任何事情。她把十字架放在一边，再次踮起脚尖，伸手换上了一个新的。在这个十字架上是一个黑人耶稣。他由深色木材雕刻而成，有着短小的卷发，宽鼻子，丰满的嘴唇，还有着和白人耶稣一样下垂的脸。
This little Irish woman straightened the cross, adjusted herself, climbed down off the chair, and began to leave the room. All of us were completely silent. Then one brave soul asked her what she was doing.
这位爱尔兰矮个子女性挺直了十字架，整理好自己，从椅子上爬下来，开始离开教室。我们所有人都完全沉默了。然后一个勇敢的灵魂问她在做什么。
Without hesitation, Sister Rosemary turned around to us and said, boys and girls, we're not sure what Jesus looked like. But we know he probably looked more like you than like me. Then Sister Rosemary turned around and walked out of the classroom. That was it. No deep discussion. No sitting down and going over it.
罗斯玛丽修女毫不犹豫地转过身对我们说：“孩子们，我们不确定耶稣长什么样。但我们知道他可能长得更像你们，而不是像我。”然后罗斯玛丽修女转身走出了教室。就这样。没有深入的讨论。没有坐下来详细说明。
In one moment, she turned Jesus from white to black. Kind of like, OK, boys and girls, Jesus is black. Deal with it on your own.
那一刻，她把耶稣从白色变成了黑色。就像是：“好了，孩子们，耶稣是黑人。你们自己消化吧。”
Sister Rosemary must have done the exact same thing in all the other classes, because from then on, all the crucifixes in our classrooms were black. I can imagine her starting out the day with a full box of black crucifixes and ending it with a bunch of white ones she had to put in storage.
罗斯玛丽修女一定在其他所有班级都做了同样的事，因为从那以后，我们教室里所有的十字架都是黑色的。我可以想象她带着一整盒黑色十字架开始一天，最后带着一堆必须存入仓库的白色十字架结束一天。
There were 20 or so classes. So she would have replaced the white crucifix more than 20 times. Each time getting on her tiptoes. Each time meeting the stunned reaction. Each time saying the same thing.
大约有20个班级。所以她得把白色十字架换了20多次。每一次都踮起脚尖。每一次都迎接那震惊的反应。每一次都说同样的话。
She could have done it on a Saturday or during a break. But she did it while we were all there. She made the change, not the janitor or the teacher, Sister Rosemary.
她本可以在周六或假期期间做这件事。但她是在我们在场时做的。她完成了这个改变，而不是工友或老师，是罗斯玛丽修女。
Here's the funny thing. No sooner had she switched the crosses that I made the switch in my head. Just like that, Jesus was black. Didn't ponder it. No rolling it over in my head. It made perfect sense to me.
有趣的是。她换下十字架没多久，我也在脑海里完成了转换。就这样，耶稣成了黑人。没思考它。没有在脑子里翻来覆去地想。这对我来说很有意义。
Everything and every one around me was black. So Jesus must have been, too. And plus, Sister Rosemary said so. The rest of my time at Saint Philip Neri, whenever I came across a white Jesus on a worksheet or in our religion book, I took out my pencil or crayon and colored him in to look like me.
我周围的一切和每一个人都是黑色的。所以耶稣也一定是。况且，罗斯玛丽修女也说了。我在圣菲利普·内里剩下的时间里，每当我在工作单或宗教书上看到白人耶稣，我就会拿出铅笔或蜡笔，把他涂成和我一样的颜色。
When you're a fourth grader, everything is bigger than you. Everyone is smarter than you, older. But when one day you realize that Jesus is just like you, Jesus is black, then everything short of Jesus seems possible.
当你是个四年级学生时，一切都比你大。每个人都比你聪明、年长。但当有一天你意识到耶稣就像你一样，耶稣是黑人时，那么除了耶稣之外的一切似乎都是可能的。
Even now when I close my eyes to pray, it's to a Jesus with curly hair and dark skin. That's probably the way it ought to be. Theologically speaking, I know it does not matter at all what color Jesus was. Who he is transcends what he looked like.
即使现在当我闭上眼睛祈祷时，也是对着一个有着卷发和深色皮肤的耶稣。这可能就是它该有的样子。神学上讲，我知道耶稣是什么肤色根本不重要。他是什么样的人超越了他长什么样。
Scholars say the historical Jesus probably looked much like the people who live in the Middle East now, just shorter. Probably not much taller than Sister Rosemary. She knew exactly how God should look in my eyes. And luckily enough for me, she was able to show me.
学者们说历史上的耶稣可能长得很像现在居住在中东的人们，只是更矮一点。可能比罗斯玛丽修女高不了多少。她确切地知道在我的眼中上帝该是什么样子。幸运的是，她能展示给我看。
Sonari Glinton, his regular job, he's a reporter for NPR News.
索纳里·格林顿，他的本职工作，他是NPR新闻的记者。
[MUSIC-- "PERSONAL JESUS," BY  NINA HAGEN]
（音乐——尼娜·哈根演唱的《个人的耶稣》）
Act Four, "Not My First Time at the Rodeo."
第四幕，“我不是第一次参加这种竞技了”。
There are conversations that you have with your parents that just stay with you your whole life-- what they said, what you said, back and forths that you know by heart. You repeat them to explain who you are to somebody else, or to yourself, and who your parents were. But what if you could re-hear that dialogue decades later? Not your memory of it, but the actual words that were truly spoken. Nancy Updike has this story.
有些对话是你和父母进行的，它们会伴随你一生——他们说了什么，你说了什么，你知道这些对话内容。你重复它们来向别人或自己解释你是谁，以及你的父母是谁。但如果你能在几十年后重新听到那段对话会怎样？不是你记忆中的对话，而是真正说过的话。南希·厄普戴克带来了这个故事。
Bill Lahey was in his early 20s and on the phone with his father in 1978 when he heard a faint pinging sound on the phone. He mentioned it. And his father said--
比尔·拉希在1978年20多岁时给父亲打电话，听到电话里传来微弱的滴答声。他提到了。他父亲说——
When did that start?
那是从什么时候开始的？
It's been there all along.
它一直都在。
I never heard it.
我从来没听到过。
No?
没有吗？
Must be my bad ear.
一定是我的耳朵不好使。
There's a ping, like, every five seconds.
每隔五秒钟就有一个滴答声。
Well, that's funny.
嗯，那真是有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
Maybe we're being eavesdropped on.
也许我们被窃听了。
Monitored or something.
被监控什么的。
Yeah. Sometimes I wonder if this phone is tapped.
是的。有时我想知道这电话是不是被装了监听器。
Two decades later, after his father had died, Bill was at his dad's house in Ohio cleaning out the office.
二十年后，在他父亲去世后，比尔在他父亲位于俄亥俄州的家中清理办公室。
And I opened up a file cabinet and found 30 or 40 cassette tapes with his unmistakable handwritten notations of names and dates. And I knew instantly what they were, that he had been surreptitiously taping us.
我打开一个文件柜，发现了30或40盘带有他明确手写标记、标注了姓名和日期的磁带。我立刻知道那是什么，他一直在偷偷录我们的音。
Even at the time his father was recording, Bill had guessed what could be going on. It was the kind of thing his father might do. And he did. He recorded hours of calls with Bill.
甚至在他父亲录音的时候，比尔就猜到发生了什么。这是他父亲可能会做的事。而且他确实做了。他录下了和比尔通电话的数小时录音。
And according to his own handwritten labels, he also taped his four other children, his wife, his mother, other relatives, his priest. He recorded calls at home and in the car.
根据他自己的手写标签，他还录下了他的另外四个孩子、妻子、母亲、其他亲戚、牧师的谈话。他在家里和车里录下通话。
Recording test number four. Road noise, average to low. Speed, 60 miles an hour.
录音测试第四号。道路噪音，中等到低。车速，每小时60英里。
From the dates on the cassettes, Bill figured they were an archive of his father trying to get the people around him on to his side. Bill's mother had left his father after 37 years of marriage. Bill remembered the gist and tone of those conversations pretty well. They were memorable. And he put off listening to the recordings of them.
根据磁带上的日期，比尔断定这是一份档案，记录了他父亲试图让身边的人站在他这一边的尝试。比尔的母亲在结婚37年后离开了父亲。比尔对比那些对话的大致内容和语气还记得很清楚。它们令人难忘。他推迟了听这些录音的时间。
For 12 years, they sat in a black nylon duffel bag that he would move every time the family moved. This was a pile of information Bill wasn't sure he wanted from an era of his life he knew he didn't want to relive.
12年来，它们一直放在一个黑色尼龙行李袋里，每次全家搬家他都会带着。这是一堆比尔不确定自己是否想要的信息，来自他人生中一段他知道自己不想重温的时期。
He'd sided with his mom in the divorce even before the divorce. Since junior high, he'd been lobbying her to leave his dad. As Bill saw his father, he was smart, tenacious, and a tremendous bully with a bad quick temper and huge blowups. He got worse over time. And he was worse when he drank.
在离婚之前，甚至在离婚甚至还没有开始时，他就站在母亲这一边。从初中起，他就一直游说她离开父亲。比尔眼中的父亲，聪明、顽强，是个脾气暴躁、爱发火、动不动就大爆炸的恶霸。他随着时间推移越来越糟糕。而且他喝酒时更糟。
What Bill remembered from the taped conversations were long calls where his father bullied him and he fought back hard. He saw himself as his mother's advocate and protector.
比尔从录音对话中记得的是漫长的电话，电话里父亲欺负他，他激烈反抗。他把自己看作母亲的倡导者和保护者。
I remember him trying to recruit me in his campaign to keep his marriage together. And so my memory was me saying versions of, look, she doesn't want to do that anymore. You guys have tried for a long time. Let it go. You know, some version of face facts, it's over.
记得他试图招募我加入他保持婚姻的运动。我的记忆里我说的版本是：“看，她不想再那样了。你们已经试了很久了。顺其自然吧。”你知道，某种“认清事实吧，结束了”的版本。
So you remember pushing back verbally, arguing with him?
所以你记得进行言语反击，跟他争论？
Yeah, yeah. All the time.
是的，是的。一直都是这样。
After those 12 years of holding on to the tapes, Bill finally reached just about the age his father had been when he'd made the recordings. And suddenly Bill wanted to hear them. He felt ready but nervous.
在保留了这些磁带12年后，比尔终于达到了他父亲录音时的年纪。突然间比尔想听了。他感到准备好了，但很紧张。
Here was raw data about what I actually did in conversations with my dad. And I just took one of the tapes with me, with my name on, and went into our car in the back of our house. Partially because it was the only place that had a cassette tape recorder that I knew of.
这里有关于我在与父亲谈话时实际做了什么的原始数据。我只带了其中一盘带有我名字的磁带，走进了我们房后的车里。部分原因是因为它是唯一一个我知道有磁带录音机的地方。
And the first thing that came on was his voice pretty aggressively questioning me about something. And his voice was as clear as the day I heard it.
首先出现的是他父亲对他进行相当激进质问的声音。他的声音像我听到那天一样清晰。
So you got pretty involved there, didn't you, for somebody who didn't want to take sides?
所以你参与其中了，对吧，对于一个不想选边站的人来说？
Yeah, I did. Certainly did.
是的，确实。肯定是的。
His father was talking about the fact that Bill and his four siblings all sided with their mother in the divorce in one way or another.
他父亲谈到了比尔和四个兄弟姐妹在离婚中以某种方式站在母亲一边的事实。
So why did you do it? What, were you feeling sorry for your mother?
所以你为什么那么做？你是在同情你母亲吗？
No.
不。
For being oppressed? You'd think she was going around in a wheelchair. How would you feel, Bill? And have that kind of a situation where the mother hen is being protected. From who?
因为她受压迫？你以为她是坐在轮椅上吗？比尔，你感觉如何？那种母鸡受到保护的情况。保护谁？
She's got everybody believing that I'm a goddamn bully. She's so psychotic that she's got everybody believing that I'm a bastard. That's how psychotic she is. How would you feel if you were me, Bill?
她让所有人都相信我是个该死的恶霸。她精神错乱到让所有人都相信我是个混蛋。她就是这么精神错乱。如果你是我，你会怎么想，比尔？
And I listened for probably two minutes. And I was like, OK. That's what they are. This is just really intense. I took the tape out, went back and went into the house and told my wife about it. And didn't listen to them again for, I don't know, three or four months.
我听了大概两分钟。我心想：“好吧。原来是这样。这真的太紧张了。”我把磁带取出，回屋告诉了妻子。然后又有三四个月没再听。
When Bill went back to listening for real, what he heard was his father pushing one main point with him hour after hour. Which was, how about you talking your mother into trying again?
当比尔真正回去听时，他听到父亲在小时复一小时地向他强调一个重点：你谈谈让你母亲再试一次怎么样？
How do you feel about that assessment?
你对那个评估感觉如何？
To give it a try?
去试一试？
Yeah.
是的。
[SIGHS]. Well, just from talking to mother over the months, I see no real sign of changing her mind.
（叹气）。嗯，光是过去几个月里和母亲交谈，我没看到她改变主意的迹象。
But has anybody really tried to, Bill, forcibly, persuasively? Is it fair that she doesn't try, whether she wants to or not? And the answer, obviously, is no it isn't fair. To have it go down the drain and lose the war for a few battles without trying is, to me, absurd.
但比尔，真的有人试过吗，强行地、有说服力地？她不尝试公平吗，不管她想不想？答案显然是不公平。在没尝试的情况下就让它付诸东流并输掉战争，对我来说是荒谬的。
Yeah. Well, I guess because I see it more than just a few battles.
嗯。好吧，我想因为我看到的不仅仅是几次战斗。
No, I said there was a bunch of them. What the hell's the difference? There were a lot of good times. Why do you look at the black part?
不，我说过有很多次。这有什么区别？有很多美好时光。为什么你只盯着黑色部分？
Well, Dad, because I didn't that time that things worked well. I mean, maybe when I was very young.
嗯，爸爸，因为我没经历过事情顺利的时候。我的意思是，可能当我非常小的时候。
You have no-- remember anything? We had no happiness, Bill?
你没有任何……记得什么吗？我们没有幸福，比尔？
I didn't say none.
我没说一点都没有。
You just said you never saw the times when we did.
你刚才说你从来没见过我们做得好的时候。
A period. I mean, when I say things, you know, just generally.
一段时期。我是说，当我说这些话时，你知道，只是大体上。
Oh, well, you have a short memory, Bill. I'm sorry to say that. We used to go up to Lake Erie. We had a lot of good times.
噢，好吧，你的记性不好，比尔。我很遗憾这么说。我们过去常去伊利湖。我们有很多美好时光。
I'm not saying we didn't.
我不是说我们没有。
Bill, are you saying that there's no use trying?
比尔，你是在说尝试没用吗？
I'm not saying that. I just--
我没说那个。我只是——
What's the bottom line? Let's get down to it. This is a lot of conversation. Tell me what your attitude is. Are you advocating that we don't try?
底线是什么？让我们深入讨论。这谈话太长了。告诉我你的态度。你是主张我们不要尝试吗？
I'm just taking--
我只是……
No, I want to know.
不，我想知道。
Why do you take so long to answer?
为什么你回答得这么慢？
Kind of like, say something. You know, just don't sit there. I was less confrontational than I remember or expected. But I could remember that thought process that I went through.
就像是说点什么。你知道，别只坐在那儿。我比我记忆中或预期的那样对抗性要少。但我能记得我经历的那个思维过程。
You know, if I say X, he's going to blow up. If I say, Y, I'm going to throw my mom under the bus.
你知道，如果我说X，他会爆炸。如果我说Y，我就是把妈妈扔到公共汽车下。
I know what Mother's-- at least from what she tells me, this has been something that she's obviously been thinking about a long time.
我至少从她告诉我的内容知道母亲的……这是一件她显然考虑了很长时间的事情。
Not no long time. Maybe four or five years. Bill, do you know that her mind might be affected? And she may not be herself psychologically.
不是很长时间。可能四五年吧。比尔，你知道她的心智可能受到了影响吗？她在心理上可能不是她自己了。
Four or five years?
四五年？
Bill, do you realize that her mind might affected? She may not be herself psychologically.
比尔，你意识到她的心智可能受到了影响吗？她在心理上可能不是她自己了。
But for that long of time?
但那么长时间？
Yes. Would you like to see us happy if we can arrange to be together?
是的。如果我们能安排在一起，你想看到我们幸福吗？
Sure.
当然。
Why don't you say that?
你为什么不那么说？
Where was the warrior in me? Where was the stand up person that was willing to call a lie a lie, you know, willing to draw bright lines and say, I won't even put up with having a conversation about this?
我心中的战士在哪儿？那个愿意把谎言称之为谎言、愿意划清界限说“我甚至不会容忍关于这件事的谈话”的坚定的人在哪儿？
And some of these conversations go on so long. I mean, 45 minutes, an hour. And he's just hammering away at you and at the points he's making. Why did you stay on such a long time? Why not just say, Dad, I got to go?
这些谈话持续了太久。我是说，45分钟，一个小时。他只是在你和他的观点上捶打。为什么你待那么久？为什么不只是说：“爸爸，我得走了”？
Yeah. So I was living in Wisconsin during a lot of this taping. I felt badly that my mom was back there, basically by herself dealing with him. And I think I had some notion that by staying on the phone with him, you know, it's like a little bit of the rodeo clown. You know, those old rodeo clowns would be sent out. The cowboy would be bucked off the bull.
是的。所以我在这段录音的大部分时间里住在威斯康星州。我感到很糟糕，因为我妈妈回到了那里，基本上独自应付他。我想我有一个想法，通过在电话上和他待在一起，你知道，就像一点点罗德奥小丑。你知道，那些老罗德奥小丑会被派出去。牛仔会被公牛摔下来。
To distract the bull?
去分散公牛的注意力？
Would go out to distract the bull.
去分散公牛的注意力。
Bill wasn't crushed by the difference between what he heard on the tapes and the tough line he'd remembered taking with his dad. But it did throw him off balance. He really had seen himself from the time he was a kid as a warrior standing up to the strong, protecting the weak, a sort of superhero when it came to arguing against his dad.
比尔并没有被他在录音中听到的与他记忆中对父亲采取强硬态度之间的差异所压垮。但这确实让他失去了平衡。从他还是个孩子的时候起，他就一直把自己看作是一个保护弱小的战士，一个在反对父亲时如超级英雄般的人物。
But I was less heroic. It was like I was more pragmatic. It was less of an epic struggle of right and wrong and more mundane than that.
但我没那么英勇。这就像我更务实。这不是一场关于是非的史诗般的斗争，而是比那更平凡。
I mean, what kid fantasizes about being a pragmatist?
我是说，哪个孩子会幻想自己是个务实主义者？
[LAUGHS]. Right.
（笑声）。对。
Bill says his mother thrived after the divorce. His father, he says, stayed more or less the same. He married again, divorced again.
比尔说他的母亲在离婚后蓬勃发展。他说，他的父亲基本上保持原样。他又结了一次婚，又离了一次婚。
Bill kept up a relationship with him his whole life. That had been his other goal during these calls. Besides protecting his mom, not losing his dad. He had thought about that even during the worst arguments. Better a long silence than words he couldn't take back.
比尔一生都保持着与他的关系。这是他在这些电话中的另一个目标。除了保护妈妈，不失去爸爸。即使在最糟糕的争论中，他也想过这一点。长久的沉默好过无法收回的话。
Bill saw his father once or twice a year every year after the divorce. And he spoke to him by phone every few weeks until he died.
离婚后，比尔每年见父亲一两次。他在他去世前每隔几周就和他通电话。
I'll call you back soon. Or you could call me in the evening.
我会很快给你回电的。或者你可以在晚上打给我。
So your number's the same.
所以你的号码还是那个。
Sure.
当然。
All right.
好的。
And any time you want to chat.
任何时候你想聊天。
All right.
好的。
OK. So I will talk to you soon.
好的。所以我会很快和你谈。
OK, I'm glad you called. Take care.
好的，爸爸。晚安。
OK, Dad. Good night.
[CLICK]
（点击声）
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program.
南希·厄普戴克是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC-- "GET THE MESSAGE," BY SAGITARIUS"]
（音乐——人马座演唱的《收到消息》）
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar and our senior producer Julie Snyder with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔和高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普戴克共同参与。
Production help from Tarek Fouda. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our office manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
制作帮助来自塔雷克·福达。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。
[ANNOUNCEMENTS]
（公告）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International, WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. His friend Mars has been making these cute little radios. You know these little volume knob, and a tuning knob. And Torey cannot shut up about it.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行，WBEZ对我们节目的管理由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生监督。他的朋友火星一直在制作这些可爱的小收音机。你知道这些小音量旋钮和调谐旋钮。托里谈论个没完。
Hail, double knob, children of Mars.
向“双瘤”、火星的孩子们致敬。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC-- "GET THE MESSAGE," BY SAGITARIUS"]
（音乐——人马座演唱的《收到消息》）
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。